all right let's move on to the next
category next category screen grab of
the year
this is a good one there's so many good
ones
yeah this is one of the like it could
easily be like a 15
nominee yeah there's so many good ones
and there's just
every single week i get a laugh just
seeing at this time yeah yeah yeah but
there are some ones every time i go into
the subreddit there's a new
screen there's a new server every
episode this is a new screenshot that
just makes me laugh
guys here's one yeah all right let's
look at the nominations
i've never been more like the barack
obama giving yourself a medal meme
yeah because i i can't recreate this
have you seen like the gif
of it like the build up to it is
i was joking about peasants or something
and being rich and i was like
like somehow somehow
i can't i can't recreate it like no
matter how much i try like
it's got about it's got about seven
different emotions yeah it's like all
packed in the one
i can't recreate it yeah it's just what
i want to drink it's just like it's just
like the perfect emotion yeah
and then we got uh me stirring the
omission this is from the stream
from the stream right it's just me
fingering pickerel juice yeah i just
completely forgot about the screen grab
until it got nominated again
and then we got uh degenerates versus
normies we can't see we can't see the
entire one we'll have to show you the
full thing on screen right yeah but it's
pretty good it was used in a lot of
memes
and then we have uh i think dance
favorite right yeah this is this is this
is uh
this is one of this is also one of my
favorites sherry looking at the skirt i
mean
this is like this like the equivalent of
like the corona bottle thing where you
didn't realize
you were on camera because you guys were
talking about and i had it in my hand i
was like i was just curious i was like
she wearing pants let's
find out it was just such a cultured man
moment yes hello
i am a fellow gentleman of culture the
men couldn't wait until we were off
camera
he was like i have to look right now
because you two were talking
i thought it was this camera and then
use the [ __ ] middle camera
where it's showing me two hits so that's
all moon on
my favorite one is god's crooked suit
why are you doing it like this
ship's like i totally and your face is
out of disgust
what i love about i love this photo
because it's usually paired with
oh man i don't know all of these are so
good like i
i wouldn't be upset if any of these are
lost i mean i think
the wine one is probably the most iconic
yeah i feel like that one might win
that probably my like my personal
favorite was the degenerates versus
normies
it's just such a perfect such a perfect
juxtaposition yeah and
and i'm glad it was the one it was like
you can see that me and sydney were on
the same wavelength i can't even
remember
this moment but i'm just like there's
nothing that encapsulates when me and
sydney hang out with these two more than
like
this one screen grab every time we hang
out there's some other other screen
grabs i like like we had the uh
the uh one where the cycling special
where gantt was cycling and i'm out the
window smiling yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and the one where me
and joey are sitting uh in the
the chairs watching oh yeah the green
screen
turned into a meme yeah that made its
rounds oh yeah yeah yeah
i also like the one where uh ladybird is
like sharing the mic oh yeah yeah
it's like whispering that was pretty
good there's so many good ones but all
right but there can only be one winner
ladies and gentlemen
grab of the gear let's go trash taste
the water a screen grab of the year goes
to
the corner
i can't read it it's a classic did this
one win by a lot i'm i assume this one's
gonna win by a landslide
wait what was the second place uh second
place was um
sydney oh okay with 24.1 percent
very good very good yeah i mean there
was no beating this this this was the
iconic one of the year that was i think
used the most like one of those north
korean-esque shrine pictures of this
just like that in the office
an army needs to walk past this foreign
some of them where i was like i'm pretty
sure i know it yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're actually on many where i
think i know no no this was one of them
just because i've seen this picture so
many times i just get like five replies
of this it's the perfect reaction i'm
not even mad you know what i like seeing
it
is that vain of me i don't care it's
funny i like it if that was me i would
it was just a great [ __ ] face i feel
like i don't even see me when i look at
it
i just see a funny ass reaction i don't
know why
it's just like the perfect twitchy mode
you know
it's one of my twitter